And now the old scout master.
Did you guys hear my dog?
Yes,
She's a foxhound and if something walks by the house, like within a half a mile of the house,
she gets very interested and needs to let me know.
I think I've heard her before,
So that's going to be edited out. huh,
Well, we'll see. if it turns out to be kind of interesting and funny, we'll leave it.
Hey, this is podcast number 88.
Hey, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. this is Clark Green.
Peter LaRue wrote in about last week's interview with Mark Dyer and Doug Metz about Shelter Box
And if you haven't heard that one, you know, make sure you get a listen to it.
Peter wrote in and said that he saw Shelter Box at the World Jamboree
and he's been very keen to investigate introducing it to scouting in South Africa.
So we're glad we could help make that connection.
Also from Tom Gillard- and you're going to hear from Tom later on.
He said we had our full district camperee this past weekend.
Some of the other adults and I have been talking about the respectful distance we need to establish from scouts.
I informed the committee at the last meeting in the intent of moving the adult camp about 150 feet down the road from the troop at the camperee.
I informed the senior patrol leader of this on the ride out there
And frankly he was a little shocked and I think maybe a little bit scared.
But everything went very well, mostly because we adults couldn't see all the small things that we might interfere with.
A few times I went down to the scout campsite. I stopped at the entrance and I asked permission to enter
And that kind of shocked most of them.
I would ask the senior patrol leader, if he had the schedule,
Tell them to stop by and pick us up on the way to activities. and they did, without any clock checking on my part.
Now they didn't get there as early as I would have, but they really weren't very late either.
I gave the senior patrol leader a safety review and basically we left him alone
And that turned that weekend into a relaxing one for me and the other adults.
Not that I wasn't looking through the woods to see how large the fire was and things like that,
But the adults could sit around and talk about stuff and just be a little more relaxed.
After lunch I stopped in to see how things were going with the scouts.
They had done all the activities and weren't going back out.
I asked them what they were going to do with themselves that afternoon.
They said: well, we're going to do some advancement with the younger scouts.
I almost had to sit down.
Anyway, they had a good time.
Sunday morning I was asking the scouts what they would be telling their fellow scouts
That they didn't make the camperee.
Would they tell them what went on? What did they think of it?
I emphasized that it was a trusted responsibility
And I think they really understood this because they wanted to continue.
I've been kind of reluctant to try this step of being a little bit more at arm's length from them,
And I've been reluctant for quite a while.
But this experience reinforced what you've written about on the blog
And talked about on the podcast and, of course, what Baden Powell had to say.
That's all for now, and that's Tom Gillard in Tollahoma, Tennessee,
And that's a great report.
It's a challenge to let scouts do things for themselves. sometimes
It's a constant challenge for me. I know it is for most of you,
But when we do let them do things for themselves,
That's when the program really starts to click, isn't it?
I mean, that's when it really kicks in.
Let me take note too, that there is a new Eagle Project booklet
That has just been released within the past week
And a new advancement guide that's just been released.
These are two pretty key pieces of knowledge for every scout leader to have,
And we'll be discussing them on the blog and in the podcast in the coming weeks
Because some of the changes are very encouraging indeed.
There are some things that have changed
And that we will need to adjust some of our procedures
To recognize those changes,
And there are some things that have changed
That are an emphasis of what was there before,
But they're just spelled out a bit clearly
And I have taken the time to review both of those documents.
I think it's fantastic.
I think it's going to make a whole lot of difference,
Especially in those kind of disputed, troubled eagle things that happen,
And you know, boards of review and scout master conferences
Kind of sets a clearer path for how to resolve conflicts.
What both of these new documents do
Is emphasize the importance of reaching the scout with the program
And to make sure that our policies and procedures are designed with that in mind.
So next up, and for the rest of the podcast, is our first scout master panel.
That's right, we've got a panel of scout masters put together
From all over the country.
There were three of us this time
And I'm very interested to see what direction this takes.
I think we've got a pretty solid thing put together
And I think you'll enjoy listening
This time around. our question for the panel was:
What would you tell a new scout master?
What would you tell somebody who's considering taking the job?
And I think you'll enjoy it,
And that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
And everything that feels just as it should.
You're part of a life there.
You're part of something good,
If you've ever wandered lonely through the woods,
If you'd ever been out walking new and known.
So, on the scout masters podcast today
We're trying a little experiment.
We've got a panel of scout masters put together
And we're going to talk about,
After we've been through this for several years,
How we would advise a new scout master,
What we would tell him that we know now
That we didn't know then.
From Vera Florida,
Larry Geiger is joining me,
And Larry has been a scout master
For several different troops over the years
And is now an assistant scout master
For the troop. he was most recently scout master
For troops 720 there in Vera.
How you doing today, Larry,
Good doing good.
Tom Gillard is in tele home of Tennessee
Where he is the scout master of troop 402.
Welcome to the podcast, Tom.
Thank you very much.
And Walter Underwood is a past scout master
Of troop 14 and is now the assistant scout master
For their venture patrol.
And Walter is in Palo Alto, California.
Howdy, Walter.
Hi there,
Larry, we said that you were a scout master
For several different troops.
If we put all those years together,
How many years do you figure you spent as a scout master?
I think it's 14,
Tom. same question:
18,
18 years.
And Walter,
It's about six, though I started up with Cubs
So I've worked my way up through assistant and leader all the way.
Were you involved in Cubs, Tom?
No, we didn't actually have very many Cubs
When I was growing up. we didn't,
But my kids were,
And I guess I did the weeblows thing
With the boys before we went into Boy Scouts
When they started camping.
That's what got you interested.
Yeah, that's it.
How about you, Larry,
Have any involvement with Cubs?
I was the weeblows leader for
A one year from my eldest son.
You guys all have the experience of having worked in Cubs, scouting,
Making the transition up to Boy Scouts.
What kind of person makes a good scout master?
And I'll turn to you first, Larry.
I think a lot of scout masters are kind of in a middle position somewhere.
They're not usually CEOs or guys that are really, really busy.
It's usually somebody that understands leadership
And can do some of that,
But it's not necessarily a business owner or somebody that's so busy
They don't have time for it.
And then it's somebody that loves working with Scouts,
That wants to really get in there, either with their own son
Or, if they don't have a son,
Somebody that really wants to work with them
And to learn and to grow.
What would you add to that time?
Well, the person would have to be willing to try different things,
To go a little bit outside his comfort zone,
Get out of the box type stuff.
And, Walter, what would you add?
I think, especially coming over from Cubs,
You need someone who has the patience to watch boys
Fail as they learn.
If you can watch boys try to light a fire for 30 minutes
Without saying anything.
And the other thing is you have to be really solid in the ideals,
The oath and law and what you're about,
And that it's citizenship, character and fitness,
Because you end up explaining this all the time.
It's not the same as soccer teams,
And especially with parents.
You need to be very solid when somebody comes in
And says: why isn't my son a patrol leader?
Because this is how we do it.
So patience, are you as patient now as you were
When you started out as a scout master? Walter,
I have learned the scout master position,
Which is one hand in your pocket
And the other holding a cup of coffee.
How about you, Larry?
I think I'm way more patient than I was when I started-
Less flappable, more unflappable,
And all three of you had sons involved.
What are we looking out for when we take on that position
And our sons involved?
I don't want to show favoritism to my own son,
So there's a whole lot of. let one of the other assistants
Take care of stuff that happens with your son
And you'll take care of his son.
Larry, what was your experience?
My guys and I don't think had a problem with that.
I've asked them about that.
They're both fairly independent
And they both had good friends in the troop
That they hung out with.
I did a few of their scout master conferences.
Some other assistant scout masters did them.
I think it worked out pretty well.
Walter, what was your experience?
When I was asked to be scout master,
I asked my son about it
And he thought it was a terrible idea.
He came around
And in fact he was SPL
And I was scout master
And that worked out pretty well.
But it was really nice to have
Hand that over to another scout master
And he was still SPL
And let me be able to see them work together.
So patients having a little bit of
You end up having those things that you do as a father
And those things that you do as a scout master
And that can be kind of fuzzy at times.
It can be kind of hard to figure.
What challenges do you expect a new scout master
Is going to meet,
Sometimes trying to do
I can do it better myself
Or it won't get done right if I don't do it.
Mentality,
And you've got to realize that
It will get done.
It won't be the way you wanted it to,
But it will get done
If you ask
And everybody's behind the program.
So you've got to be careful with that.
I'm a delegator
And I don't have a lot of problem with that
When I give something to somebody
You know.
Before long as people come around,
I give it all away.
The truth is I just don't have much to do,
But for some reason I don't have a lot of anxiety
Like some guys do
About that.
I was a scout from
My 11th birthday,
The day of
Until I was 18,
So I had kind of a background
I did. I thought
I think for me
Working with the scouts
Wasn't as much as
Working with the parents, the moms
And the committee.
That opened up more of the challenges sometimes.
I want to get back to that.
Larry, you were fairly experienced in scouting.
You had some background.
Tom, how about you?
I joined when I was 11
And eagled out
At 18.
I was one of those late eagles
But I went all the way through the program also.
And, Walter,
I was a cub scout.
I was a scout through 18.
I was on summer camp staff
One summer when I was in college,
So I had plenty of experience.
I thought:
Do you think that somebody without any background in it
Can actually take the job on?
The guy that preceded me
Was a retired navy guy.
He was never a scout
And he had daughters
And he was scout master for three years.
He did very well
And he was a very good scout master
And really loved the kids.
So, yeah, I absolutely think that
That if it's the right person, they can do that.
I think that with the network,
That there is something like this
With the internet, with roundtables,
With the training,
Yes, you could do it.
You could be a good scout master
With no background in the program.
The two scout masters that followed me
Have been both.
Either one had a scouting experience growing up,
And so you certainly have to help them along
As scout master emeritus
And give them hints here and there.
We're also lucky.
Our boys are very, very particular
About leading the operation
And if you try to step in,
They will let you know
That it is a boy led troop
And you're doing it wrong.
And so, even if you don't have
A whole background of
Scouting experience as a youth,
That you can still do this
If you go and take advantage
Of the different support networks
That are available,
If you kind of listen to people
Who've got a little bit of experience.
Larry, you started talking a little bit
About working with parents,
Working with other volunteers.
I think that might-
I'm not saying that
You saying that would put people off.
But I think that would be a pretty big factor
In somebody who's thinking about
Taking the job on
Is whether or not they could stand doing that.
I don't know.
I don't think I would have done very well
If I hadn't had very, very strong committees.
Both times I've been a scout master.
I've had basically
The whole time rooms full of people
From this troop
We average about 15.
In my last troop
We average 20 to 35
In a committee meeting
And with all of those people
In the committee
They get to know
Kind of what's going on
And don't freak out about
Quite as much
As people that are totally on the sideline,
Particularly moms of single,
Single moms.
They're not in committee meetings,
They're busy.
It's just harder sometimes, I think, for them.
I have a letter from a mom.
It's about me
Inflexible and insufferable
And I don't know
A whole bunch of ins
And unfortunately my committee chairman
Had a sense of humor
And I don't want to.
I don't want to be negative about that,
It's just
It can be a challenge on occasions
Working through that,
Like you said, when parents don't understand
Why their son's not patrol leader.
You know you got to walk through that.
We're talking to somebody
Who maybe is considering being a scoutmaster,
Who's a newly minted scoutmaster?
And they're encountering some of these things
And you do get through them, don't you?
Yeah,
Oh, absolutely.
I would agree that a committee chair
Is really essential
And we have
Our committee meetings,
Really a parent meeting.
We have them
During the first troop meeting of the month,
Right,
And so the parents are all over in another room,
The scoutmaster's typically there
Letting the SPL run the meeting
And off we'll have the SPL come in
And explain something that's going on.
But that really helps.
I actually spent more effort
Rebuilding the connection
With our charter organization.
You know, kind of getting
Reconnected with the pastor,
Having the whole troop show up
For parish workdays
In troop t-shirts
And really just getting that back
On track,
And I want to talk more about that.
But just talking about overcoming
Those first couple of months of resistance
Or difficulty, you know,
Being the new guy in the job,
Does anybody have anything
That they specifically remember from that time?
The way I look at it-
My committee chairman and I-
Is that the committee chairman and I
Are in charge and responsible for everything.
Anything in the troop that doesn't happen,
There's not somebody to cover,
We do,
And so the idea is
Is that we don't push people
To do stuff, even the scouts.
We say: what we want is everybody to do
What they're trained, experienced
And comfortable doing.
And if you work it that way,
Eventually it takes time sometimes,
But eventually you'll find a guy
That wants to be treasurer for eight years
And he never loses a penny
Because he's doing what he wants to do.
If you'd made him an advancement chair
Or a committee chair,
You'd have had a disaster.
So you just keep working through.
And the same thing with the scouts.
Some guys don't want to be SPL,
They want to be instructors.
Some guys, you know,
It just depends.
You have to work with them
And find out what, exactly
Where they fit,
And then encourage them
To go do that
And do it. well,
Tom, do you remember
That first period after you decided
That you would go ahead and take on the job?
Was it really challenging?
It was a little bit like
What Larry was talking about.
Since we were a brand new troop,
We didn't have many adults
And I was doing a lot of the stuff.
But as we needed stuff,
Even if there weren't a position,
Even if nobody volunteered for anything,
You could always go and ask a parent.
And if it was a close-ended thing,
They would say, sure, I'll do that,
And sort of got those things off of me
Back into the committee
Or then started getting the boys
To doing the stuff.
So it started shifting back to where it should be
And leaving me and the committee chair
Doing what we're supposed to be doing.
And Walter, you talked about having to
Kind of rebuild the chartered
Organization relationship
As one of the challenges
That come easily to mind.
Well, when my son joined
We had a big year
And the troop grew from 23 to 46 scouts
And then I became
Scoutmaster that March.
So we were really adjusting
To being a more organized,
Little bit less seat of the pants
Troop
And we had really excellent
Outings chair moved on.
That was a real adjustment
To just get more people
Stepping in to do more things
Because we were bigger,
And get the scouts used to doing things
As opposed to just a little group
To knew each other as to a bigger group.
So that was
There was a real adjustment there
And I was shepherding a lot of that.
So, Walter, when you,
When your outdoor guy left,
Did you and the committee chair
Pick that up until, like, say,
For six months, until the right guy
Came along.
We did have somebody volunteer
And they were pretty good,
But they weren't nearly as good
As the previous guy.
But did you get another one eventually?
Yes, yes,
We're a most recent outdoor chair.
We've gone to be Scoutmaster
And now we have another one,
And so that's really settled down
Now that we've adjusted to the size we are.
And of course, now we just got another 20 scouts,
So we have to have another adjustment.
Well, we've talked a lot about
Importance of a strong troop committee.
We've talked a little bit about
Relating to the charter organization.
Larry, what's your experience
As far as the importance of
Having good connections with the charter organization?
I was in troop 705 for about two years
And it wasn't going really well.
So we started a new one
And both my pastors were Eagle Scouts-
The current one and then the previous one-
And were extremely supportive.
It was an excellent relationship.
How about you, Tom?
They're very standoffish
But they are in the charter organization.
He's had three sons.
Two of them have become Eagles.
The third one is working very hard
And he's in the troop
And he's in the charter organization.
So he is our link.
And one of the other key relationships
Is the relationship to the district
And the council.
What are your thoughts on that? fellas,
This will probably get censored.
I encourage people to take training
But particularly in my first troop
I kept most of my guys fairly isolated.
I went to Roundtable
And the rest of the district at the time
Was the kind of thing where
If I brought my committee data and nabbed them-
When you say that
You mean they would have asked them
To volunteer and do something.
And we ended up along the way
With 50, 60, 70 scouts
And I sent the assistant scout masters to training
And the main thing
That we had a relationship with the district
Was the district advancement chair.
But you have to have a good relationship
With the district advancement chair,
Particularly if you're going to have
Eagle scouts.
That's essential.
I don't know,
It depends on your troop.
We have troops that have trailers
And they have all kinds of gear
And the biggest thing of the year
Is the two camperees
And they set all this stuff up
And we're the guys that
You know that park at the gate
And backpack in
And go back in the bushes.
That's sort of us too.
We're a very minimalist backpacking troop.
We don't have a trailer.
The district and the Roundtables,
I think, are pretty invaluable
Because you do gain an awful lot
Of knowledge.
The other scout masters,
The other committee district people
That are there
Are more than willing to share their experiences
And you find out-
Hey, you really aren't in this by yourself
In the district
And I was the
District advancement chair
For a couple of years, I guess
A few years ago-
And that's a whole. another
Being on the district side
Is a whole another story.
I think the district is
Being associated in the district
Is very useful.
Yes, I would agree with that.
I know I'm about to find out
About the other side.
I've just been invited to be on,
To be on the district advancement committee
And help approve eagle projects.
But no, our district is
Very lightweight and helpful.
Our troop is also a backpacking troop,
As are most of the troops around here.
Like Tom, a lot of what
I get out of it
Is knowing the other scout masters
Right. there's a real comradery
Among the troops.
When I was a kid
It seemed like there was a rivalry
Between the troops,
But nowadays it seems like
Especially being an adult now.
Everybody really tries to get along
With each other because
You're doing the same thing.
Now, one thing I'll mention, that
Is, we live in Florida
And it's hot and it's buggy.
So we go to Camp Daniel Boone
And Camp North Carolina,
Which is the Asheville council.
It's in the mountains,
It's 3,500 feet,
It's cool, it's beautiful.
Again, that sets us off.
If you tend to go to your local camp,
You also make connections
That we don't make
True, more than just your committee
And the other people that are working with your troop.
You can stretch out a little bit.
You can find some help, assistance,
Some comradery with people
In your district and your council as well.
Right, the council.
The person you want to really know
In the council level,
When the council level,
Is the secretary for camping
And the secretary for advancement.
Those are the two.
Yeah, they know how to get things done,
Absolutely.
Let's talk a little bit about
Working with your youth leaders.
There's different styles of doing this.
There's different ways of approaching it.
What's the dynamic
Of the youth leadership?
So far as your role as Scoutmaster is involved,
If you focus on the leaders
And you kind of leave the other guys alone,
You begin to develop that relationship
Where the older guys
Take care of the younger guys.
Everybody's different. there,
I guess, is what I would say
Is: I've seen different Scoutmasters,
Different ways
And I'm pretty much hands off
Most of the time.
But some people are more hands on
And it seems to work for them
And the boys still do the thing
They still do- scouting.
So how you work that out
And getting to know the guys
When you're brand new
Is just something that you have to do
As a Scoutmaster,
And it's the
Especially. the senior patrol leader
Depends on how old he is,
How much experience he might have,
And if he's a go-getter
You just step back and let him go.
If he's very timid,
You have to say
You have to send him notes through emails
The week before
And let him cultivate that
For the next meeting.
So the age and maturity
Of your senior patrol leader
Is going to affect how you handle it,
No matter whether you're new or old,
Right, but we're talking about new guys here,
Right,
I guess that's what we're going to focus on.
And you don't know them.
Well, you may not-
I don't know
If you've been in the troop a while-
But if you walk in
And you don't know them,
You have to develop that relationship.
Well, that's true too, yeah,
So that's hard coming in cold.
It is a real delicate balance
Between how much do you let them
Risk and fail
While you're still responsible
For the program of the troop.
So there's a real balance
Of that sort of mentoring
While having the campouts happen
And having things happen on them
And advancement,
And it's just hard
Right.
It's one of those subtle balance
Sorts of things
That you just have to work out.
From my personal experience,
It takes a while to figure out
Exactly how it all works.
Whether you've had any experience
In scouting or not.
It takes a lot of practice
To find all the subtleties
Of working and motivating youth leaders.
Well, it depends on how much of it
Is leading and motivating
And how much of it is them finding
Their own way.
It's a little bit of both,
Because you're letting them go
To figure out their own leadership ability.
Some of them, you know
You can't teach every kid
Because every kid is different.
You teach them some principles
But then they have to go and do that.
Some kids are just loud
And a little bit bossy
But it works for them.
You know another kid try that
And you know it's just like
Who are you?
And then other guys
Are just kind of quiet
And they're more in the background
And yet guys just walk over
And say: hey, what do you think we should do?
You know so their leadership styles
Can be very, very different
And they have to kind of
The scouts have to kind of find that,
And that's where you encourage them
In their leadership.
But you don't drown it out.
Hey, you know you're not doing.
You know senior patrol,
You're not doing enough of this,
You know, or that kind of thing.
As opposed to well, you really handle that. well,
How can you take whatever you did there
And use it over here in this situation?
And they have to figure that out.
You can't say, well, then you need to do that
Because that won't work.
Is there anything that you did,
Any of you did, particularly
That you would look back on and you say
I would, really I would warn somebody
Not to do that,
Had a great experience.
Part of our part of growing
Was that we split into more patrols
And so we had the leaders,
Scouts, do that,
And they did a fantastic job.
And then one of the
We have assistive patrol leaders
Associated with the patrol,
So they're kind of liaisons,
And so someone had been with one of these patrols
For a long time,
Looked at the result and said,
Well, some of the scouts I've been with
For all these years are now in another patrol,
And could we change all this?
And I let him change.
And that was a mistake,
Because we that haunted us
For a couple of years,
Because they had it arranged
So they were kind of younger,
Kind of a bench for leadership.
So when the patrol leader moved on
And so we ended up with one patrol
That didn't have anybody to fill in
For the next patrol leader,
Another patrol with too many older scouts
That all aged out at once
And boy, yeah, I let the adults
Mess with the boys' decisions.
That was a bad idea.
So, Walter, what you're describing is
The boys set up their own patrols
And then you allowed
The adults to kind of overrule that.
They just made some adjustments.
Yeah,
It was very finely balanced work.
Boys did a fantastic job.
Yeah,
And it threw it out of balance.
Hmm, that's interesting.
The word I would use is meddling,
And I think that's
One of the regrets I would have
Is I have meddled a couple of times
In SPL elections
And patrol organization
Once or twice.
Shouldn't have
We started to mess around with
The patrol arrangement once
And backed off?
I don't remember exactly why,
But we backed off of that.
But we meddled around
Trying to do troop rules.
You know,
And the troop rules are
Her in the book,
So you know.
And what rules are you talking about specifically?
We were trying to get
Punishment rules.
If you do this, then this will
Happen,
And we had a trouble-
Trouble child-
And we were trying to lay down more rules
To cover what he was doing,
Instead of going.
You're not living up to the oath and the law.
These are the rules.
So that
That came about and lasted
For a very short time
And it's.
It's gone away now.
So meddling,
Like thinking that you're smarter than the boys,
Because a lot of times we're not.
Well, I don't know
That. it's that we're smarter.
Sometimes we are smarter,
Sometimes we could do it better.
But when we meddle,
We take away that learning process.
Whether they would do it better, the same or less,
It doesn't matter.
The point is it's not
Whether we're smarter or whether there's a better end result.
The point is that they did it
And they learned one way or the other from that,
And that's the main.
The other thing that came up was
Overlaying a whole lot of other things
Of the program in the way of rules
And regulations and stuff like that.
I've made that mistake,
My hands up.
I definitely did that in the past
And found out that
If most of those rules and regulations
Had any merit to them,
They would have been there in the first place.
Can't go wrong if you stick to the program.
So we've talked a lot about
The different challenges that you come across,
Some of the relationships that you need to think about,
The way that you work with the scouts,
How about at home, How about dealing with
Your family, your wife, and
How that all works.
I mean, everybody knows
I go to work and I'm a scout.
My wife and boys have always supported that
I'm a scout guy.
Everybody knows that.
Everybody that knows me is the scout guy.
I guess if you stick with it for a while,
That's going to get attached to you,
That's associated with you
And with your wife.
So it's a family thing
Completely.
You do become
The program.
People do recognize you
Because of stuff you've done through the scouting
And
Your wife
Does become the wife
Of the scout master.
Whether they know her or not,
They know that she's the wife of the scout master
But she's got to support it.
And
My boys,
You lost your ticket
But you still get to go on the ride?
Absolutely.
You're almost as old as the rest of us,
Walter. what do you think about that?
I'm a preacher's kid
And my mom
Always made it very clear
That she was not the preacher's wife,
She was Merle's wife
And that was her number one,
As opposed to being just another
Hand around the corner.
And that was her number one
As opposed to being just another hand
Around the church.
And so I tried to make sure that
It's really my thing
And it's really
I get fantastic support from the family,
But that they're first.
Now
Tina thought it was a little weird at first
With all these little kids running around in blue uniforms
And it is a little weird.
But they
She's actually came around and volunteered
And organized the boards of review
For the past several years
And has really enjoyed
Talking to the scouts and the boards.
So it's been great support.
But it's really important
To keep that
In balance.
So this group has a number of years
Behind them as being a volunteer
Leader in scouting
And it's a lot.
It's a lot to ask of somebody.
It makes
There's challenges and demands on your time.
Any regrets?
Would you recommend it to folks?
Absolutely,
No regrets,
No regrets.
I would encourage people to make sure that
You find some enthusiasm in it.
If you like to hike,
Make sure that there's
That you're really having fun doing.
Yeah, I agree,
No regrets at all.
It's the greatest thing.
Well, you're the scout guy
I know.
Well, listen,
I really appreciate everybody joining in.
I hope folks will find this
Valuable.
If you would like us to talk about
Another subject in scouting,
Or if you're having a particular
Problem or challenge,
Get in touch
And we'll do it again.
Thank you, Clark,
You're welcome,
And Tom
And Walter.
It's been a pleasure
And it's been good to talk to y'all
And we'll talk again soon.
Well, thanks for listening to this edition
Of the scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
You can read the scoutmaster blog
At scoutmastercgcom
And you can subscribe to the podcast on iTunes.
Just look for scoutmastercg.
When you do, feel free to leave a comment
Or a rating,
And you can also call in
And leave a voicemail comment or question
At this number,
484-734-0002.
Of course, you can follow us
At the scoutmaster blog on Facebook
And scoutmastercg on Twitter.
You'll also find us over at google plus.
Look for Clark Green.
Finally, you can email me
With your comments and questions
At scoutmastercgnet,
C-G,
At Verizonnet.
Now, the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
Are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
Nor are they endorsed or sponsored by
The Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, it's just me. I got a microphone
And I'm trying to help scout leaders
And maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
Well, before we leave you today,
Let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
I highly recommend
The Scoutmaster Podcast.
Good luck to you
And good camping.
Thank you, sir, until next time.